McKenzie is in Illinois hi McKenzie
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hi thank
you so I just have a question I am 24
I'm currently debt free and I have my
six months in an emergency fund good and
I have my 401k set up as well and I'm
just trying to figure out what I should
be doing with my money now if I should
increase my 401k if I should do it with
short term investments or say for a
house that I eventually would like to
buy I probably would put 15% of your
income into the 401k you're not you're
not saving any extra money in the
emergency fund once it's there it's
there you don't need to add to it then I
would start a separate account that I
start saving towards the house okay
sounds like you've got you've done a
really good job managing the money you
got coming in you're probably making
good money too so it sounds like what do
you make seventy five thousand yeah
you're doing great for 24 that's awesome
and so yeah I would set up 15 percent of
my income going into 401k you don't need
to add anything else the emergency fund
and then any other savings I can do
would be towards my down payment fund
over in another account okay would you
recommend looking at like maybe getting
a financial investor for or looking into
more like investments with my Ani or
just keeping it in a different account
for savings depends on how quick you're
gonna buy the house how quick you think
you're gonna buy probably not for about
five years I'm relocating quite a bit
for work right now so okay well yeah you
could sit down with one of our smart
Wester pros click smart Wester at Dave
Ramsey comm we're not in that business
but it's those are the people we
recommend and they do stuff the way we
teach you click sit you click on it it
drops down I'll list them in your area
you decide who you want to sit down with
but they've got the heart of a teacher
and they can help you pick out what you
would want to do something really ultra
conservative if you're gonna do an
investment there because you don't want
the stock market to dive on you right
about the time you get ready to buy yep
and if it did go down you want to make
sure you're you know that it's not going
to go down as much as the market does so
you've got something that's super
conservative
fund and that's what I would look
towards if I were doing that so yeah sit
down with smart Vista Pro they can help
you set that additional up if you want
to work a little harder if you got five
years or more to invest I'm fine with a
mutual fund investment generally you're
gonna make money statistically in the
history of the market you'll make money
during that time if you pick a decent
fund